Neue Kinder zum Abstimmen Zemke nein nicht wirklich
Exzellenz neues Kidz Bop I Natürlich macht die
verdächtige Animation digitale
Starts Trennkoch Otto wichtig nein
meetha cheela Stefan hat den ganzen Müll
richtig einige der Fedora haben
Geldgeber Kirill Baiioons in Interviews und
und Fell nicht umgedreht  up is muslim and spotted or
snitch darren and shalom so dog to look
like as a seal of natural stone
Invasion to study of email to on school
goes in mobile vision Metsu Einkommen
Wien Amsterdam entre Indian Vesta Park
die Osmanen winkelten das einzige Budget
für hallo
guten  morgen früh geht es mir gut und wie geht
es dir gut du bist flip oder stefan ich bin
stefan und hallo ich kreise herum ah
morgen schau ich flipp perfekt okay wie
geht es dir gut ja danke der
film läuft gut in niederlande und
Deutschland hat erst vor ein paar Tagen angefangen, ja
ja, so ungefähr an diesem Wochenende in Deutschland, in
dem ich gehört habe, dass es die Kasse Nummer eins war,
also das ist wirklich großartig,
okay, das ist in Ordnung, ja, und wie hat das
alles angefangen?
Ich denke, es war am Anfang sehr, sehr klein,
ja ja, wir haben damit angefangen,
äh ja, ich denke, meistens war es wie vor zehn
Jahren, als wir als Freunde anfingen,
nur Skizzen zu machen, es sind mehr lustige
Filme aus drei Minuten oder
so, und wir haben das gemacht  ein
fernsehsender mit den
gleichen schauspielern unsere freunde sind auch ein
zerstäuberproblem von der maske auf ja ja
aus dieser kleinen stadt in einer bindung von einem
scotch und so ok
er lebte zu der zeit in den
grübchen das ist der größere ort  in der nähe von
wimperntusche und reifen von ist nicht offen und aber wir
kannten uns alle von früher
und wir fingen an, lustige sachen zu machen
und
und es gab kein fernsehen, aber es war
kein wirklich großer erfolg oder so
und dann war unser plan  wir wollten eigentlich nichts
längeres machen und wir
fingen einfach an neue
skizzen ohne budget zu machen und aber niemand
wollte es, weil es zwei routen waren oder
zwei nicht glaubten, dass es
eine art ja-erfolg werden könnte  Also haben wir es
im Internet gepostet und dann, aber wann
war dieses YouTube fünf Jahre, alles nur
Skizzen, zehn Jahre, ja, da lagen ein
paar Jahre dazwischen, denn
als alles begann, war es so, als wäre es 10
Jahre her, als wir gingen  zur
Filmschule und er arbeitete bei Interference, oh
ja, um diese Zeit und dann nach
Filmen, die wir irgendwie aufgegriffen haben,
weil sie wirklich mehr machen will,
und wir bekommen all diese
Auftragsfilme nur umsonst, aber wir
wollen es wirklich  etwas machen, das sich
um Sachen drehte, die wir mochten und das
war um fünf, ja 2005, ja, und dann haben
wir mit diesem Blockflubber gearbeitet, es ist ein
holländisch-holländischer Block, und dann haben wir gepostet oder
skizziert und die niemand haben wollte
und die dann wirklich gut funktionieren, weil sie
waren zu unhöflich ja ja ja es gab
zwei Wege und die Leute glaubten einfach nicht
daran, da fühlte es sich wie
Wissen an - und die Sache war, als
wir es über einen Fernsehsender machen wollten,
sagten sie nein, wir wollen unsere Meinung  n
wir wollen etwas
bewirken, ja, für uns ist es wirklich wichtig,
einfach das zu tun, was wir mögen, sonst könnten wir
einfach besser bei McDonald's arbeiten. Ich
glaube, ich habe gehört, dass sie dort nach Leuten suchen,
also vielleicht, wenn jemand
bei McDonald's arbeiten möchte, okay  ist es noch
möglich und dann haben wir ja es war
du kannst es teilweise in deutschland versuchen okay ich bin am
strand in der ich bin beschäftigt ich bin beschäftigt anna es ist
schwierig für mich
was ist a du weißt schon okay okay okay mach
[musik]
voraus  du tauschst etwas für
die Synchronisation für dein Handy, weil du
es selbst synchronisierst ja ja haben wir,
aber wir haben es gelesen, okay, es war alles
aufgeschrieben, aber ähm
, dann hat es im Internet funktioniert, es wurde eine
Art Hype und dann haben wir uns unterhalten  zu
Comedy Central und sie waren der erste
Sender, den wir gewagt haben, es mit uns zu machen, aber
alles nur, was wir wollten, sie haben uns die
Freiheit gelassen und dann haben wir ein paar
Skizzen mit den Charakteren mit neuen
Kindercharakteren gemacht und jetzt gibt es neue
Kindercharaktere und  Sie wurden ein großer
Hit o  Im Internet und im Fernsehen
war es wirklich eine Kombination, wirklich
dankbar, dankbar für das Internet. Ich
meine, das ist für uns der beste Weg,
um direkt zu sehen, wie die Leute reagieren und ob es
ihnen gefällt, und das wurde ein Hit
und dann und es war  kein Problem,
solche Streckenskizzen in einer Fernsehsendung zu zeigen, es
war ein Problem, es gab ein paar
Skizzen, es gab zwei Strecken, aber wir
hatten geplant, wir haben besprochen, dass wir
sie einfach machen würden, und dann würden sie
wählen, welche sie ausstrahlen würden und
welche  Eine waren zwei Routen,
also machten wir am Anfang zwanzig
Skizzen oder so und die erste, denke ich
, ist gut für etwas,
und acht waren zwei Regeln, so etwas wie
Sammeln, und schließlich fügen sie
alles hinzu, weil es zuerst wie
Schnipsel waren, die sie hatten  Es gab nur
zwischen den Sendungen und du hast nur eine
Skizze gesehen und als Zuschauer hast du
uns angesehen, wie sie ist, was zum Teufel, was ist das
und und und wenn du alles zusammenzählst,
tanze mehr und es funktioniert besser  und dann
kannst du es wirklich unhöflich machen, auch weil
es im Kontext steht und ja, das und
es wurde wirklich ein Hit im
Internet, wir haben einen Song gemacht, mit dem
repräsentiert, ja, es heißt og backpal,
das Ding, das auf Platz eins kam
Holland Wow und ja und dann äh ja,
wir haben diesen Plan, einen Film für
eine lange Zeit zu machen, wir, ich meine, das war irgendwie
unser Traum, manchmal in unserem Leben einen Film zu machen,
etwas Unglaubliches, ja, und
wir waren auch im Fernsehen zu sehen
Wir mussten interviewen, als wir sagten, dass es so ist, ich
meine, sie sagten, was sind deine Träume, ja,
mach einen Film, und ich glaube, einen Monat später wurden
wir von I Works, der Produktionsfirma, angerufen
, um ein Treffen zu haben, und wir haben unsere
Geschichte erzählt und und noch einmal wir  gesagt
, wir wollen es nur machen, wenn
wir die totale Kontrolle haben und sie haben
es nicht gesehen,
jetzt haben sie daran geglaubt, ja und ja,
und jetzt gibt es neue Kasturba, ja, okay,
aber in Deutschland ist es nicht für alle
Leute erlaubt, wenn  Sie sind unter 16 Jahre alt Sie
a  Du darfst diesen Film nicht sehen, ja
, schade,
ja, aber es war ein großes Problem, ist im
Gleichgewicht, es ist ein 12-plus-Zug, oh ja, okay,
sie sind hier und da ein bisschen leichter
in Holland mit HS, aber in
Deutschland in der  Am Anfang wurde es mit 18 plus bewertet,
oh ja, und das ist dasselbe wie
Pornos, in denen Sie jemanden in diesem Film sehr brutal ermorden.
Ja, aber es
gab ein Problem, und dann, aber
schließlich kam es durch und 16 plus
war, ja, war erlaubt  okay, wirklich
glücklich, also das ist so unhöflich ja könnte ein
problem für dich sein im fernsehen im kino
ja aber es ist immer in einem lustigen zusammenhang
oh ja ich meine es ist nicht so, dass wir
wirklich grausame sachen machen wollen, was
immer lustig sein muss, weil
es so ist  Alles für die Komödie, ja,
aber woher kommt diese Unhöflichkeit?
Es ist die Jugend in Brabant, die so unhöflich ist, oder
Ihre Jugend, was sich von der Route her verbessert,
dass das Lustige ist, eine
ziemlich wohlhabende Kleinstadt zu maskieren, und wir
hatten ungefähr 1500 Menschen, die dort lebten, aber  dort
w  Hier sind ein paar Typen, weil ich
aus Moskau komme und wo bist du
von uns allen, von McEntee bis hin
zu Dumbo's Effekt, all dies ein kleiner
Ort neben Moskau, und von
dort kenne ich ihn, ja so und das
Wort paar Typen  immer auf dem Platz
stehend mit ihrem Opal war nicht offen
Monta damals später glaube ich Opel
Astra oder so, aber es war
ein Opel, das ist wichtig und die
standen da und und und und ich war ein
ganz kleines Kind, das war sechs  oder
so und ich bin einfach immer vorbeigegangen
und es hat mich wirklich
beeindruckt, und diese Charaktere
haben uns ja eine Art Inspiration gegeben, und dann sind
wir schließlich ein bisschen größer als das
Leben geworden, aber ähm, hat eine Menge
Dinge gut gemacht und  Was haben oder sagen die
Leute jetzt im Matheland über
deine Bande, es ist ein bisschen peinlich für
sie, ja, ich meine, die Sache
ist, weil wir von dort sind, sind sie
stolz, sie sind stolz, okay, ich meine, wenn wir
aus einer anderen Stadt kommen, dann wäre es b  e
wirklich ja, wir sind wirklich schlecht für sie,
weil wir uns dann über sie lustig machen würden
oder so, und jetzt sind sie so,
weil wir von dort sind und sie
cool sind und ich meine, natürlich haben alle
Leute eine Meinung und jeder  hat eine
meinung ich finde das gut
ich meine es ist etwas das du deinen
kopf liebst das gefällt uns auch ich meine
wir sind auch ganz extrem
was geschmack angeht wir ich meine wenn wir wenn wir
schreiben machen wir einen scherz und dann mache ich  ein
Witz, Sonam umzudrehen, und es ist scheiße und dann ist
es scheiße, und dann und dann machen wir und
dann er eins, und dann ist es großartig
und es ist gut oder es ist nicht gut und es ist
auch so, ich denke, mit dem Publikum
liebt man es oder man hasst es  Ja, deine Freunde
lieben, lieben, sehr deine Skizzen oder hassen
sie, oder es ist 50/50, sie sind, was sie
mögen, und ich denke, für uns ist es wirklich
wichtig, dass ich meine, das
Wichtigste ist, dass wir lieben, damit wir
die Sachen machen, die wir machen  finde es wirklich lustig,
aber das erste große Kompliment ist, wenn
deine Freunde w mögen  Hat man sie gemacht,
waren sie auch von Anfang an nur ein paar
Flügel und dann eine Art Testbesichtigungen. Die
Regel,
wir haben sie in verschiedenen Bieren bekommen und
sie die Sachen sehen lassen, die wir gemacht haben,
und sie mochten es, also ist das
wirklich gut so  uns also schreibt ihr beide
neue kinder fast an den skizzen wie
wichtig ist bier auf lateinisch ja bier ist
immer wichtig ja wenn du schreibst
wenn du es ansiehst wir tun einfach nichts
es ist immer wichtig okay also ist
das wichtig zum schreiben an ich
rauche gerne  Gras ja funktioniert gut okay und lass
uns darüber reden
Gras und Bier okay also bist du hier Ich habe vor ein
paar Minuten hier den Feed
entlang gesehen Ich habe ein Café gesehen also bist du
wie Cafés hier versucht sie
ja ja es ist überall in Holland du
kannst  lerne sie überall, also ja, ich bin ein
großer Kunde, okay, also können Drogen
positiv sein, du denkst, wir können positiv sein,
okay, ich stehe nicht auf die harten Sachen, ja,
okay,
hallo,
hahaha, was denkst du darüber
über B und Unkraut, es gibt lustige Ti
Manchmal hat es wirklich gut funktioniert oder
manchmal nicht. Ich meine,
manchmal, ja, wir erfinden Sachen und dann
trinken wir damit und
schließlich trinken wir einfach, okay, also ist es
manchmal besser, nicht zu trinken, wenn
wir schreiben  aber manchmal ist es wirklich
gut dabei, ja ja, wenn du und
Liebessituationen passieren, trinken wir ja, und
dann verwenden wir diese Situationen, die
Dinge aus dem wirklichen Leben, und du hast in unseren Drehbüchern gesagt,
also haben wir immer ein
kleines Buch bei uns, ja, also jeder  lustige
Sache, die uns begegnet, du schreibst es
für das
nächste Projekt oder was auch immer auf, wir haben immer
eine Liste mit
Witzen  Ich habe nichts zu
tun und liege irgendwo am Strand,
dann kommt es auf, du siehst eine Menge
irritierender Leute vorbeilaufen, als
wäre ich lustig, wenn das passiert wäre,
sie haben sich den Typen geschnappt oder okay, im
Urlaub, das ist a  viel Inspiration also
Leute anschauen ja ja ich finde hassen
ist eine wirklich gute sache
hassen ja ja ja wenn man sich ärgert
aber leute ja was sagt man darüber
nachzudenken wäre cool für jeden jemand
fällt etwas vom himmel und fällt
auf ihn und er ist tot  nicht wirklich, aber
das ist in Imaginationland okay, also wenn
Hass eine gute Inspiration ist, hast du
viele Hasser auf YouTube und anderen
Plattformen? Ja, ich denke schon, aber hauptsächlich
meine ich Leute im Internet, meistens die
Typen, die neue Kinder mögen, aber sie sind es auch
Sie sind auch die großen Hasser, die das
Ding zerstören, okay, meistens auf dem
Block. Wir haben den Flubber-
Flubber-Delta-Mail-Blog gestartet, und weil unsere
Filme jede Woche dort waren, hatten wir
jede Woche mit dieser Premiere am
Montag einen neuen Sketch und die Leute
die die Seite schon lange verfolgt haben, sie
waren wie Verpiss dich, Mann, das ist unser Block
und was zum Teufel machst du hier und
aber viele neue Jungs haben es einfach wirklich
geliebt und auch Jungs, die schon,
aber du immer ev  ade it yeah ich finde
das echt gut ich meine wenn
alle einfach ganz ruhig damit umgehen und es
ganz in ordnung wäre dann wäre es
mittelmäßig denke ich und wir finden es gut das
es so extreme reaktionen gibt ok und wenn du
sagst hass ist gut  inspiration die neuen
kinder die rollen liebst du sie oder
hasst du sie oder hast du angst sie machen
was solls die charaktere von
wir sind vielleicht ich habe keine angst vor ihnen ich
finde sie interessant ja ja sie
leben für sich  Regeln, sie haben ihren
eigenen Raum, und deshalb mag ich
an einem neuen Fall, es ist ihr Dorf, es sind
ihre Regeln, ihre Welt,
es gehört ihnen, also mag ich es irgendwie
oder nicht, aber ich mag es,
wenn sie verstehen, dass sie darin sind  die Welt
oder missverstehen die Welt Ich denke, sie
nutzen die Welt für sich selbst. Ich denke, es
funktioniert wirklich gut für sie, ja, und
ich denke, ich habe viel Spaß, ja, aber
es ist vielleicht da, ja, was ist ein Gott,
wie heißt der Typ mit  sein offener
Manta Rickett finde ich ja und er ist
v  ehr stolz auf seinen offenen Munda ja
aber der andere Teil der Welt und ich
denke viele Leute werden nicht stolz auf
einen Opel Manta sein nein nein er hat sein Karma verloren ich
meine damals ich meine in
Deutschland war das auch ja a  großes Ding mit einem großen
Ziegelstein hatten wir über einen offenen Mann
Tomandamanda,
ja ja, aber das war das coolste, schnell
bezahlbare Auto, denke ich, weil ich meine, die,
es wurde ein Hit, als das Auto ein
bisschen alt war und Leute, junge Leute es
sich leisten konnten und ich  Ich meine, es ist so hässlich,
Mann, ich finde es großartig, es ist eigentlich
in Grün, ja, besonders in Grün, ja,
und es ist der deutsche Monat, auch dieser
wird aus Deutschland importiert, das ist eine lustige
Sache, der Typ lebt in Holland, aber er
ist Deutscher und er hat sich selbst gepimpt  Auto
und er hat dir sein Auto gegeben, ja, wir haben es benutzt,
weil wir am Anfang
kein Budget hatten. Ich meine, wir haben nur die
Skizzen und sie gemacht, also mussten wir die Leute fragen,
und er war ein Typ, der dieses Auto hatte
und wir  will
zuerst am anfang dachten wir
es müsste b  Er ist ein schwarzer und dann sahen wir
diesen und wir dachten, wow, das ist
wirklich grüner Mann,
okay, er ist gut, und der Typ mit seinem Auto,
der ursprüngliche Typ, dem das Auto gehört, dachte
er nicht, was sie mit meinem Auto machen
und ich er  mag es selbst auch
mit dem Auto Rennen fahren, also fährt er manchmal auf die
Rennstrecke und fährt Rennen und Rennen jetzt liebt er
es ja er liebt neue Kinder ja er ist
keiner der Charaktere ähnlich einem
der Charaktere in New Kids nein nein ist
weil der Kern  Charaktere stammen auch
ein bisschen aus der Zeit zurück, ich meine,
es ist inspiriert von den 90ern, und
der Typ, dem Samantha gehörte, ist ein
wirklich cooler Typ, und er mag die
House-Musik, aber mehr interessiert sich jetzt mehr,
also denke ich, dass das anders ist
was denkst du über die neuen kinder
kinder es ist dir manchmal peinlich
so eine komödie zu machen oder du hältst dich
darüber auf wenn du vielleicht auf der
premiere bist und wichtige leute triffst oder oh
nein es ist halt das
was wir das mögen wir das  ist, was wir denken
Lustig, also für uns ist es, den Traum zu leben.
Ich meine, das Beste, den besten Job, den du
haben könntest, ist das, was wir gerade machen,
also ja, okay
, ich wünsche dir viele Filme in der Zukunft,
also neue Kinder, oh, wir haben jetzt neue Kinder
Mitternachtsreihe haben wir dann und die
nächste, die dritte ist gut, ihr Kinder,
Atombombe, fangen wir mit Atombombe an,
ist Nigel, okay, das ist irgendwie wirklich cool,
ich meine, als wir den ersten Film drehten,
als wir den ersten Film schrieben,
waren wir so  Okay, das ist es, ich meine, das
ist cool und ja, ich meine, wir hatten
keine neuen Ideen und als wir
diesen ersten Film drehten, bekamen wir all diese
Ideen für den zweiten, also werden wir sehen,
wie es läuft, denke ich  Das
Wichtigste für uns ist, dass wir etwas machen
, das besser ist als das erste,
also Lucas NACO wird
es wirklich großartig werden, okay, also
wirst du jetzt und in der Zukunft großen Erfolg haben,
ich denke, das werden
wir hoffen, aber  Wir finden
es wirklich cool, dass es
in Deutschland funktioniert  nd das und das und dass
ihr das aufgreift und es liebt Ich
meine, ich denke, das liegt auch daran, dass
man sich die ich sage blöden Ferien ansehen kann,
es wurde jemals auf eine lustige Art und Weise gemacht. Ich
denke, ich denke, das ist eine Schule und
es ist eine Art  Wiedererkennbar, ich meine,
in jeder kleinen oder großen
Stadt hängen diese Typen mit ihren
Autos und und und das Lustige ist,
dass ihr in Deutschland auch diese Art von
Wiedererkennungswert habt, ja, wir haben diese Kultur,
ja, und Energie und in Belgien  Es ist auch
so, dass ich das wirklich cool finde,
dass es ja irgendwie ich weiß nicht,
Grenzen und Grenzen überschreitet, dass ja,
ich bin sehr stolz, dich zu treffen, weil es
unsere Helden in Deutschland tun. Danke
, das ist lustig,
du